this is the dictator scorpion  growing up to eight inches in length it  is one of the largest scorpions in the  world  for its colossal size the dictator  scorpion has relatively weak venom so  for defense it resorts to its enormous  claws they help it to catch prey and  ward off other scorpions  located within the region of west africa  the dictator scorpion is nocturnal  spending most of its life underground  sometimes burrowing as deep as six feet  unfortunately size doesn't matter when  it comes to the preservation of the  dictator scorpion with their natural  habitats being destroyed by  deforestation its future is uncertain  this is the dictator scorpion  [Music]  you